to write the Sofia code was really
showing up and that whole process so
um can you give some insight into what
that process was like and how long that
took and the experience of it I don't
know why I just feel very emotional
right now it took me seven years to
channel the Sofia code because every
word that was channeled had to work on
me first and
um when the vision that I share and the
preface of the Sofia code was given to
me uh to you know Channel it to write
this book for the Divine mother I was a
broken person I was you know I was
shattered by what I had survived and so
every teaching every Divine genome
activation every
Step Closer towards the ascended masters
I had to believe that I was worthy of it
that I was worthy of the gift of being
given I had to rebuild my self-esteem
and I had to allow these extremely
powerful crystalline teachings to move
me from such extreme trauma into a place
of
um deep reconciliation with myself I
wouldn't say
um
you know I went into a space of Serenity
in the process because I'm still working
on that
but what I what I I have managed to do
is to
come into the full connection with my
higher self and and learn how to say yes
to embodying that higher
self-consciousness just a little bit
more every day and I spent a lot of time
sometimes between 12 to 14 hours a day
in a writing room and meditation
um yoga listening writing rewriting
because every time the teachings would
come in I could only accept them as much
as my Consciousness was ready to receive
them right and then as they would work
on me then the ascended masters would
come back and they'd be like okay and
now here's the next like the download on
what we've given you and so there were
there were many
um versions of the Sofia code until I
knew it had crystallized into how I
could best serve it and uh and the last
year of of writing it happened actually
at Mount Shasta California which is
where I received the vision original
only to to channel the book and so that
last year I also was constantly in
ceremony I had a home by the national
forest with a view of the mountain and I
would go out I would make offerings
every day I pray at my medicine wheel
pray at all the altars that I created
um
do water ceremonies
you know it was just constantly hiking
in the mountains to connect with the
ascendant Masters connect with Telos
which is the Lemurian city of Light
Within Mount Shasta the the people of
Telos are extremely powerful and
grounded they helped me really ground
what a Cosmic transmission the Sofia
code
um is so it was
you know
I was
eating in a very strict diet drinking a
lot of water from the mountain like when
I left Mount Shasta it was
after the severe code was published it
was like coming back to Earth or
something like I was just so focused in
that Heavenly realm with that mountain
it was um it was a real powerful journey
to go on these ascended masters are just
so available they're just they're ready
and waiting for us to believe that we're
worthy of them being spiritual guides
for us and so
um I find that overcoming the worthiness
factor is often the biggest piece for
light workers and and just believing
that a master of like would actually be
interested in our daily human life and
the truth is they absolutely they
absolutely are and mother Mary who we're
focusing on this year is one of the most
amazing spiritual guides for that
because she she shares in the Sofia code
like everything about your daily life is
important to me
it matters to me Isis talks about that
too in the Sofia code because where else
does ascension happen it happens in our
relationships it happens in our family
it happens in our businesses it happens
and how we show up every day to life
whether we show up or not and so I think
people have a skewed idea about what the
ascendant Masters are interested in
they're interested in us and waking us
up in our within our daily life not
extracting us from our daily life
because this is where we make the
greatest impact
um and so
we we created a curriculum called the
Stargate one curriculum and it walks you
through every chapter of the Sofia code
multiple classes and it teaches you how
to kind of it's simultaneously let go
and allow these cinemasters to step in
and start guiding you and mentoring you
and um beyond your understanding
um and how to also identify the signs
and the practices that you can just
easily incorporate into your daily life
like creating an altar that you visually
connect with of like hey that's my
intention for today it's sovereignty or
empowerment or I wanna feel closer to
Isis or mother Mary and you know you
just place a picture there you place a
you know a statement or intention we are
at a pivotal time in in human history
for our species most of our species is
in a state of Amnesia and I cannot
remember how many actual resets we've
gone through how many Global disasters
how much our species has been enslaved
and persecuted and oppressed and so the
ascended masters
um you know they they come in to this
Matrix they live these exceptional
Avatar level lifetimes to to mirror back
to us our true Sovereign potential but
there's you know there's only so much
they can do because in one lifetime
because it there has to be a large
enough Collective Awakening
for us to break free and Quantum Leap to
an to a new paradigm of liberation
from from these unseen yet extremely
Insidious forces that continue to
do what they're doing to humanity and so
the ascended masters want our
sovereignty they want for us to take our
Awakening seriously and to consider that
we know religion has attempted to
separate us from our Divinity very
purposely for a very long time because
it is our Divinity that has the power to
wake up within this Matrix and to decide
to unplug from all of this programming
that's keeping us separated from one
another and and separated from our our
creative power to to birth a new
paradigm based in sovereignty based in
light and based in our true potential
um and so
they specialize in how to recover from
trauma and then also of course once you
stabilize from the collective trauma and
the viral programming
um you you have the opportunity to
actually take in their teachings and
start to embody your higher self embody
a different uh Your Divine Consciousness
which is like an operating system that
over time
you're going to unplug from every last
illusion that you've been plugged into
with the Matrix programming so that's
what they're all about they're but they
can't do it for us
and that's why they're ascended Master
that's why I only work with these
particular Cinema Masters because they
are all about sovereignty and all about
us doing our own work Opening Our Own
Hearts taking this like this journey
um everybody's individual Journey counts
and if enough Hearts awaken if enough of
us accept that we are sovereign and
divine
we will no longer need these oppressive
experiences for our spiritual awakening
humanity is unconsciously addicted to
being oppressed to stimulate its
Spiritual Awakening
[Music]
um
is there a critical mass percentage I
feel like I've heard about that is that
true
I feel that very deeply I mean I'm not
going to throw out like some random
number but I I have seen in many visions
that and I believe is happening in many
ways right now I I really do I think
technology has allowed a certain
cross-section of the population to
awaken in an accelerated way
um I think it's a bit of a hot mess
um because there's a lot of people
searching and and not really knowing
where to look and and there's a
restructure happening within their lives
whenever there's when there's a
transition it's like Things Fall away
and have to be re-built and that's the
process yeah there's a lot of chaos
right now in in that kind of like you
said the melting down of of disengaging
I mean what happened over the past few
years was really surprising that level
of Oppression
um and lockdowns actually caused a lot
of people to stop art
railing red pills on YouTube in the
middle of the night and so we actually
do have a large cross-section of
humanity that is waking up I want you to
elaborate a little bit on the Amnesia
there's been a really intense
Interstellar War over the future of
humanity that's been raging for quite
some time on this planet and
it's the need is real for us to start
envisioning what a truly Sovereign
Paradigm of truly awakened
beings awakened to the truth of their
Divinity because if you're awakened to
the truth of your Divinity there's
nothing you can't do do you know what is
happening
where people sell their soul and why
they do and how they do it well a lot of
them end up
um
having to give in to the blackmail
that they and that they walked right
into
I know from from direct experience that
though that there are very real Satanic
rituals and very real programs that go
far beyond what anyone uh most of the
public could ever understand
um directed by intelligence agencies and
and interfacing with a civilian cover-up
of trafficking homes
um like the one that I was constantly
shuttled back and forth from as a a
cover-up for where I was really being
taken every night
um it's
it's it's a lot for people to take in
when here's the other piece you know
where there the powers that be are
constantly traumatizing the population
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen